when you bring me out
can you introduce me as Joker these
Stars might have done a little more than
acting when performing for these roles
For Better or For Worse stick around to
find out I stepped outside of myself and
looked at what I was actually doing and
it was kind of disgusted and horrified
number one Viggo Mortensen has a history
of taking his roles a bit more seriously
than his fellow actors while working on
Lord of the Rings Vigo undertook some
challenges that immersed him for Better
or For Worse in the world of Aragorn he
went a long time without certain daily
hygiene practices and during days on end
without doing things like brushing his
teeth while filming a scene Vigo was
performing a minor stunt of kicking a
helmet when he shattered his toe Legend
has it Vigo went so far as to ask
director Peter Jackson to keep that take
as he felt it was the best performance
this take actually made it into the
Final Cut
number two winning an Oscar for a
performance in a musical is no easy feat
to prepare for portraying the troubled
Fantine in Les Miserables and decided to
spend months eating as little food as
she could eating only oatmeal and
lettuce when she did it was so deep in
my character I'm like I think I'm a
vegan now like I think this is it she
also subjected herself to prolonged
bouts of isolation in an effort to make
her life just as miserable as her
characters for Better or For Worse
Anne's work on this character brought
home the Oscar in 2012. here's hoping
that the misfortunes of fontine will
only be found in stories and Nevermore
in real life number three this one
really turned his life on its end for
his role in The Pianist actor Adrian
Brody wanted to understand the emotional
distress of a Jewish musician struggling
to survive war-torn Warsaw Poland
preparing to play the role of vladislav
Brody challenged himself with losing 31
pounds of body weight and learning the
piano to take his suffering to the next
level sold my car and I disconnected my
cell phone and broke up with his
longtime girlfriend it wasn't for
nothing though Adrian Brody became the
youngest actor to ever win an Oscar for
best actor at the age of 29. number four
the life of a ballerina is no delicate
dance ask any professional ballet dancer
about their training regime and they'll
let you know it's one of the most
unnatural and physically demanding forms
of entertainment that exists today
Natalie Portman did not shy away from
this While She Was preparing to play
this role in Black Swan taking her
challenge dangerously close to a
Breaking Point either physical or mental
Natalie undertook a sparse diet that
included eating only almonds and carrots
she also began practicing ballet for
eight hours a day started
serious ballet training it was
definitely challenging number five
Hollywood audiences are no strangers to
drastic body Transformations on screen
preparing to play his role in Dallas
Buyers Club this actor found himself
losing 30 pounds the point of being
difficult to recognize it just happens
it's an intuition it's a guttural
response to a character and a script but
what really puts Leto on the list for
taking it too far are his actions when
playing Joker in Suicide Squad Jared
decided to play some unusually cruel and
unsanitary practical jokes on the rest
of the cast and crew while this might be
something that has been tolerated in the
past from actors playing principle roles
Leto's role in Suicide Squad only saw
about 10 minutes of screen time we've
had a lot of fun doing it number six
it's hard to imagine what it would be
like to live with blindness but not for
Ray Charles's biopic actor Jamie Foxx to
prepare for the role and to help make
the performance appear more authentic
fox used prosthetic eyelids that
effectively made him unable to see it
was no easy task as Jaime suffered from
frequent and debilitating panic attacks
that at times threatened to delay the
production of the film number 7. too
pretty or too smelly Holly Berry wanted
the role in Spike Lee's jungle fever so
much that when Lee didn't seem keen on
casting her Holly took it the extra mile
Spike Lee believed that Holly Berry was
too pretty to play the role of a street
woman to show him otherwise Barry delved
deep into the life of a streetwalker
spending time in a real drug den and
giving up bathing for the duration of
shooting the production really got to
shed my physical self that beauty
pageant image number eight it took took
many roles and many nominations for this
actor to finally win an Oscar we can't
help but wonder if after each almost win
this actor felt the need to do something
dramatically different while preparing
for his next role maybe that's what led
the Revenant actor Leonardo DiCaprio to
give up his plant-based food diet and
eat raw bison liver while shooting this
film he even went so far as to sleep
inside real animal carcasses to get a
feeling for the Wilderness survival
experience would not have been the same
experience had we not really been there
in these environments number nine this
actor has a Next Level commitment to
modifying his appearance for pretty much
every role we've seen him perform but
there are a few times where he might
have taken his transformation a little
too far one might be the time he gained
40 pounds to play the role of Dick
Cheney in Vice or how about the time
Bale lost an alarming 63 pounds for his
role in The Machinist leaving the actor
in a state of health that almost took
his life I mean I remember at the time
it was like not the smart thing to do
number 10 playing The Joker Ledger has
been credited with making this villain
memorable to his credit this probably
had something to do with the mental and
physical transformation that ledger took
on in playing this character but at what
cost we might even say that Heath Ledger
pushed himself farther for the role of
Joker than he had for any of his other
roles with Heath's dedication to this
transformation came sleep deprivation
exhaustion and heavy use of a sleep
medication while preparing to play The
Joker Heath Ledger isolated himself from
the rest of the World by hiding away in
a hotel for six weeks Ledger's
transformation into the Joker was so
immersive that it was hard to tell where
the character ended and the person began
while it might not be directly related
some view Heath's preparation for this
role as the cause of a mental health
breakdown that ultimately claimed his
life whether that's the case or not
Heath Ledger's death meant a huge blow
to the entertainment industry his work
as the Joker was the final chapter of
his beloved and short acting career
number 11. Heath Ledger wasn't the only
actor to struggle with the role of the
Joker the origin story for this
character saw Joaquin Phoenix starring
in the title role of the Joker striving
for a more authentic portrayal of this
downtrodden character Phoenix lost 50
pounds for the role in the beginning
you're exhausted Joaquin made this
transformation so quickly and
drastically that maintaining the weight
loss took a bigger toll the actor
developed an eating disorder while
shooting this film he became obsessed
with his body weight and after shooting
ended he struggled to get back to a
healthy mindset regarding food and
fitness we realized that it was wrong it
was just the the wrong approach number
12. this actor has been both praised and
feared for this role playing the title
role in Monster the Jeffrey Dahmer story
Evan Peters receives compliments for his
uncanny portrayal of the killer as well
as criticism saying that the retelling
of this story is too sensitive for
viewers while getting the bad guy
feeling right might be what an actor
strives for in a role the preparation
and emotional Fallout can be enough to
make one want to turn down the offer
Peters has said that taking on this role
was one of the hardest things he will
ever have to do in his career and that
in order to do so he was going to have
to go to really dark places and stay
there for an extended period of time the
Jeffrey Dahmer story is is so much
bigger than than just him for Better or
For Worse these esteemed actors seem to
find a way to challenge themselves in
ways we'd expect to see more from
Olympians or professional athletes we
know this couldn't be a complete list so
what do you think who did we miss let us
know in the comments below